over the past two years you've likely
taken a covet rapid antigen test and you
probably know what to do
swab
swirl and wait for results
a unique biochemical reaction involving
saline tiny particles of gold and paper
with antibodies is helping to give us
quick and relatively accurate results
i've never felt more attractive in my
life okay three
four mississippi five
today kate is taking a covet test while
explaining the biochemical reactions
15 mississippi i'm gonna go the other
way okay now i'm gonna do the disgusting
thing and stick this in the back of my
throat
okay okay that's all i can do all right
an epidemiologist named michael mina he
is strongly suggesting for this
particular variant for omicron that you
swab in the back of your throat and your
nose if you're gonna do the rapid test
and so we're just looking for the
highest viral load some people are
swabbing their nose and getting a
negative and then they swab their throat
and getting a positive and that is just
supporting the fact that omicron is
definitely living in our throat we are
having a high viral load there and it's
more easily detected if you swap there
once we've collected our sample the
chemistry starts to begin and molecular
forces take our sample in a buffer
solution so the buffer solution is
almost entirely salt water and so it's
like 99.7
salt water which is really sodium
chloride in water on top of that we have
a conjugate acid and a conjugate base
and so these are two different versions
of a phosphate molecule one is called
sodium hydrogen phosphate and the other
one is called potassium dihydrogen
phosphate and they lock the solution's
ph into about a ph of 7.4 this is where
the chemistry comes in the acid and the
base in the buffer solution create a
conjugate acid-base pair
a conjugate acid and base are two
different molecules that are almost
identical except for one hydrogen atom
so one piece has the hydrogen atom one
piece does not and buffer solutions are
resistant to big changes in ph so if an
acid comes along the conjugate base is
going to eat that up and keep it at a ph
of 7.4 if a base comes in the conjugate
acid is going to eat that part up and
again lock the ph in at 7.4 that ph of
7.4 the same ph is our blood helping to
mimic the conditions of the human body
[Music]
one
two
three four beautiful
now that our sample is locked in with a
ph of 7.4 we can see whether we are
positive or negative and that tiny spot
where it says s
that's where nanoparticles of gold
reside
such a tiny amount of gold in there you
couldn't sell it you cannot see it you
can't turn it into a necklace or
anything it is absolutely minuscule the
gold is connected to an antibody and so
there's kind of like a chunk of gold and
an antibody right here and if that end
protein from the covid virus is present
in the specimen antibody one is going to
reach out and grab it those antibodies
are immune responses to a specific
antigen an antigen is the part of the
virus that is easily distinguishable so
technically pollen could be an antigen
any foreign body that comes into your
body could be an antigen but a lot of
times we talk about it in the context of
a virus and so if gold nanoparticle plus
antibody one plus covid virus goes up to
that t level antibody two now reaches
out and grabs onto that covid virus and
locks it into place so you've got gold
antibody one covid and then antibody two
stuck on that t line and now boom you've
got a color change so a positive test is
going to happen right away as soon as
that gold nanoparticle reaches that t
level and the antibody grabs onto the
covid virus you're going to see that
color change now a negative test is
essentially a lack of a positive test
and so what we're doing is just making
sure that in that allotted time that t
level never changes colors now there are
some caveats as to how accurately your
test results come in
number one would be if you swabbed
correctly lab scientists are getting the
best results because they know exactly
how to perform these tests followed by
healthcare workers their second and then
the third is the regular the rest of us
that are just at home doing that second
thing that could detect your tests is
your viral load so how much of that
virus is actually sitting in your body
and there's also ways people cheat the
test in fact a few tick tocks have shown
tests with coca-cola zero sugar
strawberry juice or monster energy get a
positive result these rapid tests are
very ph sensitive that's why we use the
buffer to lock our sample into a ph of
7.4 if we start introducing something
like soda which has a ph around three or
something like juice which has a ph
around four you're going to immediately
mess with the ph of your sample and
that's going to completely negate the
result of the test and you might get a
false positive you might get a false
negative but it's just definitely not
accurate so parents out there if your
kid is cheating by using soda or
something to get a false positive to get
out of class the best way you can figure
that out is grab that original buffer
solution shake it over that tea line and
if it was messed with if soda or juice
was used you're going to immediately see
it switch back and you'll get the
accurate result which would likely be a
negative now for the first time
everybody no matter who you are what you
look like what your gender is you are
actually going through these at-home
tests and i think that's really valuable
and kind of neat that we're all at home
scientists i truly hope we use this
technology to move forward with the flu
that would be my goal if we could use
this every single season if you think
you have the flu test yourself before
you go outside wear a mask still i would
love to see that moving forward because
that's just going to be incredibly
helpful for our public health